motor trend magazine has named Pontiac  car of the year Aria car of the year  import car of the year awesome import  car veered car of the year ten best list  every year for six years the 10 mask on  the jury's alexis has been running to  best overall car line in initial quality  data was right the most appealing car in  its class it's for 2009 Motor Trend  trunk of the highest ranked midsize car  initial ball 2012 motor trend car of the  year highest ranked vehicle appeal among  large premium car most appealing midsize  car two years in a row only vehicle twin  corn drivers 10 best 2014 north american  truck of the year appealing compact  premium car by JD Power Honda builds  more Top Safety rated cars in America  than any other brand you like don't have  you